hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
January 30th
2023 what's going on how are ya
I don't know how loud this podcast is
gonna be I'm on the road man
um went out golfing with some friends I
played like [__] but I didn't give a
[__] started to rain
you know nature
mimicking my feelings while I was out
there
um I don't know
some people find the game frustrating I
find it extremely boring after four
holes
it just kind of is like what are we
doing out here
like it feels like a dead-end job to me
you know you [__] put the ball in the
hole and you're like all right there
there would I get on that say one two
three
seven eight not nine I got a nine on
that
and you're like all right good that's
over but you know I put the ball in the
[__] hole it's over and then what
then here's another one that new day
new day it's gonna be a good day you
know I'm gonna [__] you know
stay right down the center just not
gonna pick my head up
um I kind of realized today that
um I don't have the time or the desire
to get good at that activity
played on a public course
which is always fun
and I was kind of looking forward to the
whole you know
I mean my whole thing is is if we're if
we're playing 18 the only thing the only
hope I have is the refreshments
at the ninth hole
and uh we got there after the ninth hole
or whatever and the whole [__] place
was closed no trash cans
I mean it was kind of uh I don't know
sort of a lovely [__]
that we played on but let's get let's
get to what I want to talk about this
week
the NFL playoffs
um before I get to that though all the
sports fans oh [__] I saw a [__]
great movie
saw a great movie this week that I think
is nominated for a bunch of awards I saw
the whale
with Brendan Frasier
um who plays a big boy a big boy uh
dealing with some family issues there
you know getting the stuffed crust pizza
and whatnot
trying to reconnect and everybody in the
movie absolutely crushed it uh Sadie
sink
uh Hong Chow make sure I say all the
names I probably saying I'm wrong but um
I thoroughly enjoyed that movie so it's
about a bigger fella
you know and he's got some problems and
uh there's no spoiler there I'm not
going to say anything else I learned a
long time ago how not to ruin a movie
when I saw
I almost said The Hunger Games
that's not what it was what was that
movie
about the well now I'm gonna ruin it
spoiler alert I mean the movie came out
like 30 years ago it was a chicken she
had a dick back in the day you could say
a chick with a dick
Crying Game
I'm with Mike bertolino from ATC
uh The Crying Game
I remember that I had no idea what that
movie was about you couldn't know
you know
because if you knew then when the old
meat Hammer came out
you wouldn't have been surprised
I can't imagine the meetings
do we show it do we not show it in the
[__] trailer right now you know that
the guy directing it or the lady
was like uh listen no caulk in the
trailer
you know come on that might be the
selling point they're like what are you
talking about it's the [__] early 90s
No One's Gonna go see this
and I ended up seeing that movie it was
a [__] great movie
and what I loved about that was I had no
idea what the [__] was going to happen
and that was right around the time when
they started doing the movie trailers
where they would show you basically
right through halfway through the third
Act
and you knew the hero wasn't gonna die
you know only they only do that
occasionally
you know
um
I could name a few movies but it would
rule okay fast forward through the next
here's when the hero dies
all right I would say to Live and Die in
LA
hero dies in that one
another one coming at you uh Leonardo
DiCaprio in The Departed
chop me up and feed me to the poor
um and what other what other one
um
was it Hannibal Lecter no he lived
was he the hero I don't remember
he was like one of those [__] guys
that that women who like their dads
didn't stick around they'd like send
them like marriage proposals
well he ate that guard's face imagine
what he'd do to my box right
you know that logic
we're right now driving down the highway
and there's in front of us is a Ford
Super Duty I want to say an iconic
silver it might be a wrap
um it's a Ford F50
or 550 dually
and then he has one of those American
flags that you have to look up
it's gray and black which matches his
truck so now it's like all right
is he doing that because it matched the
truck or there's is there some sort of
ideology
behind that flag what do you how do you
guys feel
about all these groups with their
different American flags
personally it doesn't bother me
confusing because I don't know what it's
about but like you know there was always
that thing you know you never let all
glory touch the ground you don't deface
the American flag
right and now the American flag it's
kind of like the Wu-Tang Clan when
everybody went solo and everybody had
their own [__] solo album
and you know
if I was running for president God damn
it that's a [__] gorgeous Choice
isn't that a gorgeous struts rule it's
[__] gorgeous
let's see what do we got here this guy
is driving an F
450. four-door
if you had the two-door I swear to God
that would be it what a gorgeous [__]
truck that is I mean that's [__]
gorgeous I don't care if you don't know
how to fix anything
takes up a parking spot and a half
just to remind everybody that it's your
America
and I want a truck with a big fat ass
like my wife I'm gonna stand behind it
get semi-hard
um
something with some mud flaps
uh Bill how do you know he talks like
that I don't
I don't
um
anyway plowing ahead so we saw that
movie the whale
AKA Bobby big boy
Bobby big boys and uh the acting was
[__] amazing the story was amazing
the whole thing I absolutely loved the
movie could not wreck I give it they
give it five freckled thumbs up or two
freckled thumbs up I only have two
thumbs but I will tell you this before
we ended we went into the movie
I went with the lovely Nia and she said
to me
she says listen now before we go in
there I don't want you laughing
in any inappropriate moments
so I mean that's literally like when the
teacher goes the next person who laughs
is getting detention and then you have
all that you know the tension in you
right you [__]
you start doing that when you were a
little kid you held your nose you go
started doing that next thing you know
you [__] after class it's like lady
if you didn't say that I wouldn't be
laughing right now
um what are you lonely or something
um
so anyway
uh she tells me when we go in there
whatever you do don't [__] laugh in
any inappropriate moments
so of course we go in there and we get
about like
I don't know about five ten minutes in
the movie and you know
I'm trying to look around the corner so
I'm trying to guess what's gonna happen
right so I'm like well okay this guy's
got to be a hero at some point so I
started thinking like what if somebody
because he hadn't met anybody yet he's
just sort of alone eat it
and um
or whatever the hell he was doing I
don't remember and I just started
thinking what if
in the end he has to save somebody
right
and I just pictured him walking to the
balcony of his apartment
and then just leaning forward and like
literally topping over the whale a
bowling pin would and landing on the bad
guy
like sacrificing himself like that guy
in the end of The Exorcist
and it was just something about that
image that was so ridiculous I literally
I had a laughing fit and the movie
theater was a little cold so I was
laughing quietly but my wife was hanging
onto my arm so I was [__] shaking
like I was having a seizure
and she just said you know
shook her head and just whispered what
the [__] is wrong with you
and I was like why can't I be me why
aren't I allowed to enjoy the movie the
way that I enjoy it
you know you know what you were getting
into she does that all the [__] time
it's so funny like anytime we go into a
social situation before we I get in
there she literally
gives me a pregame speech
she's like all right now before we go in
there there's going to be a lot of
people in there just you know
just just be nice like don't don't say
what you're thinking and all of this
[__]
and I remember I said to her one time I
said you know if I ever said this before
you went into a party you'd have to
reapply your makeup
you'd literally be sitting there like
you make me feel like nobody likes me
right like that's what the [__] I would
be going to but you know
the rules are different
she's allowed to do it to me because for
centuries men evidently beat their wives
with mop handles legally
like right out in the street right next
to somebody you know
extracts to read all about get your
paper and there'd be some guy right next
to a newsboy
he'd be beating his wife with the mop
handle and the next day that incident
wouldn't even be in the paper
so fast forward
100 [__] years later
all of a sudden they can [__]
talk to you like what's his face
um
student Pope a Greenwich Village Eric
Roberts
when he's talking about you know
you tell her to stare at the floor when
she walks out that way she don't get to
say good night to nobody
it's totally flipped I should have got
my wife a wife beater for Christmas
[Laughter]
um
anyway you know it'll be amazing if all
women knew martial arts can you imagine
how much they would be beating the [__]
out of their husbands and and then
justifying it and then blaming you
um
that's it that's the only difference
between us and Them
not really
um I'm sure there's others other reasons
but anyway though you wouldn't know it
by me acting like an [__] here I
absolutely love that movie I've always
been a huge fan of Brendan Fraser and
all the new younger actors that I saw on
it they killed it definitely go see it
um if you laugh at inappropriate times I
would have an empty seat between you and
your wife
girlfriend or whatever the hell you're
into so you don't get a bunch of [__]
all right so there you go there's my
movie
recommendation for the week
um
yeah and write me in write me in right
into me and let me know what you think
but don't do whatever the [__] you want
you like that that's right here you're
listening to an old school liberal do
whatever the [__] you want right
I'm not telling you how to design your
bathrooms man
um all right let's talk NFL football
[Music]
and then there were two
in the Super Bowl
you got the Philadelphia Eagles
against the Kansas City Chiefs and I
don't know if you watched uh the the
anything better podcast
I don't know certain [__] uh bald
Ginger
told you to bet both of them
all right the Eagles 49ers game it
wasn't even a game Brock Purdy
just you know guy's elbow got blown out
on like the second Pitch of the [__]
ball game so I mean that was basically
it so I'm not gonna lie to you I didn't
see too much of that game
because uh
it was kind of a boring one to be honest
with you
um congratulations to the Eagles and
um
and Jalen hurts and everybody over there
everybody in Philly I'm sure you all
went to your
shirt it was like what 65 000 people
there and you all went to your favorite
Cheesesteak Place afterwards meaning you
went to 65 000 different [__] places
I've said this a million times I have
asked anybody I've ever met in Philly
what's your favorite [__] place
and they always pick every one of them's
giving me a different answer except the
second half I go what about Patsy Gino's
[__] those places those are for tourists
that's the only thing that they agree
upon
um
personally I just think it's because
tourists know that that's where you're
supposed to go so then they don't feel
silly enough
if somebody like me standing there
all I can say is if you get it with the
[__] whiz
or as I call it the golden shower
of cheese I mean it's not even [__]
cheese I mean it kind of makes sense
because what you're eating is not really
even meat you know what I mean nobody
knows what animal that is when they
slice it that then and they [__] fry
it you got no [__] idea
let's let's be honest with you if it was
a good cut of meat they wouldn't have to
put all that [__] cheese on it
and then put bread on it right
and I'm not [__] on it any more than
the steak and cheese in Boston it's the
same thing nobody knows what that's like
ankle meat and they just dice it up and
they put some cheese on it and you're
[__] half in the bag and it tastes
delicious
and you have it when you're young
right before all your dreams die so you
have this great child sense memory
about it guys it's just the best it's
[__] great it isn't great it's slowly
killing you but it's kind of what you
want
once you hit your middle age
sorry that got dark
got dark just like the meat when they're
done frying it
um I know there's probably a lot of
Bengals fans [__] moaning and
complaining I will definitely say the
laundry was
overwhelmingly flowing your way
from the mid third quarter to the end of
the game and I kept saying [__]
they're calling another penalty and then
they would go to the play and you guys
would be guilty except for that one
little Ticky tack
interference that's the one I was like
they didn't have to [__] do that one
but
um I thought the Bengals
played undisciplined frustrated football
towards the end
I mean hitting Mahomes that far out of
bounds
I mean you know he's the new lady of the
league right
you know they're going to protect them
you saw when Joe burrow got [__]
knocked down and he turned around and
looked at the ref and the ref is like
you haven't played long enough to get
that call right
I I think Patrick Mahomes has now
reached that level
you know it's it's like being a
quarterback in the NFL's like flying
Delta Airlines you got to get status
right so I think what's his face Joe
burrow is still in group two
where uh I think what's his face Patrick
Mahomes was definitely at the diamond
level
um if you you know and he earned it I
would say that so congratulations to the
Chiefs
um that was actually a great game and uh
so it's Chiefs versus the Eagles who do
you like this is a tough one
because the Chiefs have the more
experienced coach in the BTK killer Andy
Reid it's his brother right I mean you
might he looks just like him doesn't he
he does it's [__] ridiculous and that
guy was from that part of the country
I swear to God if Andy Reid ever goes to
[__] 23 and me I I say he loses at
least two uncles
um
Andy Reid was was the guy who chose the
right path
all the rest of them were in rest areas
and out in the [__] Woods or
something
so um you know what's funny was when the
eagle Mike when the Eagles won
or we're going to win the game I
immediately went to my Twitter because I
was trashing their coach when he [__]
was nodding vigorously saying I know
what the [__] I'm doing the guy's
literally winning a divisional playoff
game and he's acting like no one's ever
done that before or ever been a coach
that came in with a game plan that
worked
I know what the [__] I'm doing right
I mean am I crazy I mean this is like
psych 101 the guy he's got a massive
inferiority complex
right
I know what I'm doing
not like everybody says
so you got Nikki Fredo
going up against the BTK killer who do
you like
dude I called that Casey game so [__] I
I knew it
on paper you thought the Bengals were
going to win I said there's something
you know they got Andy Reid and they got
like and it's it's gonna come down it's
going to be close in the end and I said
[__] Patrick Mahomes is going to do a
couple of purse throws down around the
goal line turned out to be like a field
goal whatever he did those for the first
down
like the fact that that [__] throw is
legal
it's like what the [__] more can they do
for a quarterback now if that's a
forward lateral
but I guess because you don't like
you know
throw it like the old school like Bucket
Brigade
when somebody's [__] Barn was burning
down in the 1800s I guess it's not
considered a lateral but it's it's
pretty ridiculous you can't hit a
quarterback
you know he's [__] inside the park
he's outside the lines
well how about when Joe burrow did that
little [__] Shake on that guy
and got an extra few yards I'm kind of
feeling like the corner on the cheeks
was like well it's the quarterback he's
going to slide
I feel like if a corner lets up or a
safety lets up linebacker whatever
because he thinks the quarterback's
gonna slide and he doesn't and then he
runs by that guy
um the next time the quarterback runs he
should be
not allowed to slide and he should be
able to get hit
that's that's that's what I'm saying
because I feel like in crucial points
and a lot of NFL games I will see
quarterbacks act like they're going to
slide and then they keep running
not saying Joe did that but I I I find
it hard to believe
Corner got
I got tricked a little bit I don't know
I'm a curmudgeon all right so who do I
like in the Super Bowl
well who I want and who I like are two
different things I want the Eagles
all right I um you know Casey just
[__] won one by the way the Eagles
won one oh they beat us you know when
you win so many
as a Pats fan you forget you know what's
funny
Mr bertolina Eagles fans come up to me
all the [__] time
yeah
and I gotta like try to remember it it's
like you realize we won the Super Bowl
the year before you beat us in the year
after that kind of makes that like uh
you know what are you gonna do
we got a hole in one the whole before
and then you're gonna [__] come at me
about some bogey you think I give a [__]
congratulations
um
anyway uh
so I I want the Eagles to win
um
you know what I think that might be one
of the same I think the Eagles are gonna
win
um and I don't think it's because
Patrick Mahomes is is kind of hurt
um well he is hurt he's got two weeks to
kind of recover plus you know God knows
what happens
in that concussion tent
I think they got tired of sending guys
all the way back to the locker room
and [__] shooting them up they're
like what if we had like a tent
you know what I mean we could just
[__] do it there and then we could
get the drugged up horse back out in the
[__] field I mean because that's how
they look at them they don't look at
the owners do not look at football
players
like they're human
they did they wouldn't even let them
play the game
they're just they're livestock to them
um
and I have no idea what's going on in
this [__] world here I have no idea
what goes on in that tent I just don't
know why
all of a sudden it became so secretive
I got one for you what if somebody fakes
an injury every quarter and they go in
the tent
right
and inside the tent
is a Sam Rothstein type guy from Vegas
and he lets them know what are they
supposed to do in the next quarter
because he has an earpiece getting all
the lines that are coming in
now to somebody some of you that's
probably conspiracy theory
but to a good four percent of you that
makes a hundred percent sense
um I'm actually rooting for the Eagles
because a buddy of mine uh put a bunch
of money on the Eagles and stands to at
the beginning of the year
and I didn't hear anybody picking the
Eagles
all right because we didn't know that
that coach
knew what the [__] he was doing
um oh so anyway I uh I went to my
Twitter
a couple hours after the game I was just
like oh man the Eagles fan got to be
coming at me and I only had to scroll
down about 10
um
about 10 tweets whatever the [__] you
call them and somebody had sent me that
guy Nick nod in his head
uh crack me UPS whoever did that thank
you for the laugh all right so anyway
um I also missed a lot of the first game
not only because uh you know once the
49ers were with their third string
quarterback
which you know is an Eagles fan how much
[__] could you really talk
after that one you know they bring out
something that their third string
quarterback guy I mean the guy was it
was like [__]
I think it was Vince Evans the guy been
in the League's [__] 19 years
uh 17 years they brought that guy in um
I was I finally
uh tried my hand at a Sunday gravy oh
Mike bertelina
um I had some help though
um
but we made uh two different kinds of
Meatballs we had the beef pot we had the
beef and pork pot
um what's that [__] I was trying to
remember it earlier
Billy Brazil had that in one pot I
didn't have the right toothpicks where
you sew it in and out so it was kind of
hard for me to Brown it so I browned the
bottom in a little bit of the sides then
I had to kind of take it out put it in
the air fryer which you know I know a
lot of Italians would freak out but the
air fryer is a new thing all right it's
good it's like Scientology right it's
the newest the tool belief on the Block
um yeah it's a tool so it all [__]
worked out and uh we're on our way home
now
and that [__] is [__] uh heating up
so I'm bringing an actual Italian
to say uh let me know what he thinks oh
my God I am in love with that truck
I am in [__] love with that truck
finally went past it ah Jesus
um
so anyway we had uh we had some garlic
bread we had a salad we had spaghetti we
had a nice
I would do the garlic in in the uh also
in the airfryer fire yes we had all the
we had all the garlic on it the butter
and all of that and then we put it in
like the foil oh did we do that in the
oven
uh the woman helping me did it
um
I forget I forget but I was gonna make
pasta from scratch which I actually know
how to do that but I had to make my
daughter a belated birthday cake because
I make her one every year
and this year we took her to Disneyland
so
I you know she had a cake there but I
was still like I gotta make I gotta make
her one so I made this one layer
chocolate cake that I think came out all
right although I was tending to the
sauce and all of that hey don't put too
many onions in the sauce I was tending
to the sauce and I had taken the cake
out and I needed to take it out of the
pan and I left it in the pan a little
bit so the edges of the cake was a
little dry
uh where the inside was a little moist
what was what you wanted
um
people I'm basically transitioning out
of being a comedian and I'm going to
make mediocre Italian
food and baked goods
that's what I'm heading towards
um
so anyway I have to uh I've been a month
off of being on the road
and uh it's as much rest as I want to
take so I'm going to start haunting the
LA clubs
get my ACT back together because this
past week I went on stage and uh I was
just known as some of the bits I
couldn't quite remember
how they went and all of that [__] plus
I got I got some new stuff that I want
to work on
and
um
it's all gonna be good
oh man
my kid told me uh
you know I said make sure you make a
little secret wish
before you blow out the candle she goes
I already know what I'm wishing for and
it was two things
and uh one of them was a puppy
um
my son's just too little at this point
but
I'm just worried though if you get a
puppy I mean that's literally
anywhere from an eight to a 15-year
commitment
and if like they're into it for like a
weekend
and then you know you get a dog it's
basically a kid that never grows up
okay it's not moving out it's not going
to learn how to drive and it's certainly
not paying rent and now you got to deal
with this thing and uh
I don't know
I think I'm
too much
of a [__] lunatic
that I just really need to focus on
being a good dad
before I bring the dog in I'm thinking a
couple more years who knows but if I get
a dog I want a dog that I can chill with
you know so I'm thinking a bulldog but
you gotta time a bulldog
to make sure that it dies
when your kids can handle death because
the [__] thing's only gonna live like
nine years
so you can't get it right out of the
gate it's going to die when they're
[__] 9 10 years old
figure if you get it like around
I don't know when they're nine
nine and seven nine and six or something
like that then it's gonna live to when
they're like you know
15 to 18.
maybe that's a little better
I don't know you guys ever have a dog
die I had a couple dogs die when I was a
kid
it's [__] brutal the first one first
one was the worst we only had it for a
year and it got hit by a car
ugh
nothing funny in that
um
all right let's do the advertising here
for the week everybody we got we got
some advertising and we also have the
bonus
um
entertainment here of getting to listen
to me read out loud
all right what do we got here all right
oh policy genius everybody
you know we all hope we never need life
insurance but mortgage payments child
care and other expenses don't disappear
when you're gone
uh life insurance oh this crap is
talking about dead dogs this is perfect
life insurance is a reverse Casey Kasem
how many times I gotta tell you to not
come on and talking about a [__] dog
dying well I gotta rate policy changes
uh life insurance through your workplace
may not offer enough protection for your
family's needs and it won't follow you
if you leave your job
uh since life insurance typically gets
more expensive as we age Now's the Time
to buy of course it gets more expensive
you're older
are they secretly talking to robots
right now is that's what's happening
robots have to get life insurance
well anytime you go to Best Buy and you
buy something that they'll warranty they
get a warranty that's going to be the
future when robots are so [__] like
humans
when you get stopped
you know in order to prove what you are
you're either going to have to produce a
laminated life insurance policy or a
laminated warranty and that's when
they're going to know who's who
uh in the black market will be making
phonies of both
um dude there's an action movie huh we
must get the the fake warranty I am a
robot
hasta la vista baby
um policy genius gives you a smarter way
to find and buy the right coverage for
you and your family
it's a dangerous thing to do to get
policy genius right this is not I'm
sorry to get life insurance
I mean you immediately give your spouse
motives to take you out
I'm not saying don't get policy genius
I'm just saying maybe you don't tell
everybody if you got like that one
family member you could trust policy
genius was built to modernize the life
insurance industry
there I just pictured some old guy in a
wool suit next to one of those fans that
cuts kids fingers off their technology
makes it easy to compare life insurance
quotes from top companies like AIG is
that the funniest thing ever
a top company AIG those [__] [__]
nuke the are our economy in 2008
I mean they can come back but certain
comedians can't
there was a the greatest Generation
[__] died eating Alpo and dog food
because of those [__] and a few years
later they're they're a top company and
Prudential
I stand by Prudential because I grew up
in Boston the Prudential Tower
that was one of our Great
accomplishments the Prudential Tower and
John Hancock building both insurance
companies the two tallest buildings in
Boston you're telling me they're paying
out claims thank God for policy genius
they'll help you wage your way through
these murky Waters uh to help you with
the top companies like AIG Prudential in
just a few clicks to find your lowest
price with policy genius you can find
life insurance policies that start at
just 17 per month
for five hundred thousand dollars of
coverage holy [__] and policy genius has
licensed agents who can help you find
options that offer coverage in as little
as a week and avoid unnecessary medical
exams
you do any hard drugs huh no I don't all
right that'll be 17 bucks
um they're not incentivized to recommend
one insurer over another they're
claiming they don't have a side deal
Mike oh we're jaded we are jaded in this
business so you can trust their guidance
there are no added fees and your
personal information is private no
wonder they have thousands of five star
reviews on Google and trustpilot
your loved ones deserve a financial
safety net you deserve a smarter way to
find and buy it head to policygenius.com
or click in the description to get your
free life insurance quotes and see how
much you could save that's policy genius
p-o-l-i-c-y-g-e-n-i-u-s.com
[Music]
I want Dave brube back there I went into
five instead of four uh ZIP recruiter
happy oh it's all zip
damn
that was for the [__] homeless on the
side of the road the homeless most of
them veterans thank you for your service
can you imagine the experience of being
a [__] uh uh in the armed forces it's
like you sign up you get the crew cut
everybody's loving you they're
announcing you at a football game stand
up everybody's [__] cheering you go
to war you see all this horrible [__]
you come back all [__] up nobody helps
you you end up out on the street and
then the same people cheering you going
get a job you [__] piece of [__]
while they wear a support the troops
[__] button
and that ladies and gentlemen is called
irony
all right zip recruiter you know lots of
things factor into finding the right
Valentine name a few well you know a
chick that's good in the rack knows how
to make a sandwich
maybe pulls down six figures so I can
put my [__] feet up
that's a check worth getting a Hallmark
for hiring shouldn't be any different
too bad there's not some sort of
Technology
that can easily find the right person
for you wink wink nudge nudge Mike but
if you're hiring there is technology
that can quickly help you find the right
person for your open role I thought I
was gonna say open hole I was like Jesus
what are they doing here on Valentine's
Day zip
yeah uh matching uh recruiters matching
technology and right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com how does
zip
help you [__] meet desirable candidates
well what it does is it uses smart
matching technology to identify the most
qualified people for a wide range of
rules roles
what they're basically saying is they're
sifting through all the [__] to bring
you a keeper if you see the one
zip yeah
makes it easier
to send them a personal invite so
they're most likely to apply for your
job
what I re want to really catch their eye
zip recruiter offers attention grabbing
labels that speak to job flexibility
like urgent training provided remote and
more
yeah all these young kids they want to
be remote
that's going to be us when we get really
old ah when I was a kid you had to go
into the office
dad can I send my robot replacement in
for me
um
find candidates with uh you're crazy
about with zip recruiter employees
employers love ZipRecruiter for in fact
four out of five employers who post on
zip
recruiter uh get a quality candidate
within the first day see for yourself
you don't have to listen to me babbling
go to this exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com again that
ziprecruiter.com ZipRecruiter
the smartest way to hire
don't you love that pause that takes you
back to the old school reading
um oh Rocket money
rocket money huh dude you like to party
huh you got a little rocket money
[__] split an eight ball all right
rocket money everybody the average
person has around 12 paid subscriptions
think about that
then it tells me to pause for two
seconds
like that's how dumb my listeners are
that they need a full [__] two
seconds to be like yeah I probably
signed up for some [__] that I don't
remember
I wonder if they change the time with
each podcast like Marin has a smart fan
base pause for half a second
[Music]
they just listen to me read out loud all
right what do you think what's the
overrun to run his [__] listeners uh
we'll go with two seconds Puck and a
half
um if you think you're you're only
subscribed to a handful of services you
might want to double check with rocket
money you can quickly identify and
cancel all your unwanted subscriptions
this is amazing that somebody came up
with this uh rocket money formerly known
as true bill is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place by the way shout out to the people
that created it when it was true bill
and sold
to Rocket people I don't know where
those other the true bill people are but
they're somewhere in a [__] Hut
drinking a margarita over 80 percent of
the people have subscriptions they
forgot about like that streaming service
you bought to watch the just one show on
or that free trial that you never used
yeah that automatically renews rocket
money will quickly and easily identify
your subscriptions for you so you can
stop paying for the ones you don't want
simply find the subscription you don't
want and press cancel and Rocket money
will cancel it for you no more long hold
times with customer service or tedious
emailing back and forth yeah when they
don't let you cancel rocket money makes
canceling subscriptions as easy as a
click of a button over three million
people have used rocket money saving the
average person up to 720 a year
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com that's rocketmoney.com
rocketmoney.com
[__] times you gotta say it
um all right and with that we are into
the reads man for this week all right
response
to smug rugby guy
all right I'm gonna be honest with you
guys last
I don't remember when the hell I read it
this this rugby guy
basically wrote in to notify me and
everybody else in America that evidently
the Rugby World Cup not only is a thing
but it's actually going to happen in Los
Angeles in the United States I don't
know where the [__] it's happening
um
I have no idea if sometime this year
you notice a bunch of people with
cauliflowered ears shorts on with big
[__] thighs like oak trees you can
maybe say okay maybe the rugby
tournament
the World Cup
of soccer
I'm sorry of rugby is going to be here
so this guy was talking all this [__]
saying how America sucks at rugby
and I basically agreed with him I was
like well yeah because we don't give a
[__] about it
he never identified what country he was
from because he's a coward and I also
think he probably doesn't like me
doesn't even play the [__] game
so he's probably like he seems to me
like there's a lot of people that watch
NHL hockey and talk about NHL players
and call them [__] because they won't
drop the glove gloves and it never like
you know seeps into their brain like hey
I've never had a fight in my life or I
haven't had like a fight since my
sneakers had left and right written on
the tops of them right
so I feel like a lot of rugby fans are
probably like that or this guy was so he
was a smug [__] uh response to smug
rugby guy dear Billy Redrock tight
titties oh Red Rock titties I'd like to
respond to the guy who talks smacked
about USA Rugby on Monday's episode
first off rugby is as you so delicately
put it is a sport we don't care for
all that much here in the states no it
is [__] flatlined
rugby is betamax
rugby is uh an Android phone
that's just right that's an insult to
Android phones Androids are way more
yeah it's like if they were a fast food
joint they would be like what a burger
you know yeah they're around they didn't
have a quite went National
um or maybe no I would say those a and w
sandwich stance which I [__] love
nobody else seemed to anyway
um and the reason I know that is he's
talking about how it's not really known
here is because I went to the top high
school for rugby in the history of the
United States
Jesuit High School in Sacramento
now out of all the [__] cities that I
would think would be good at rugby I
would have guessed an East Coast one
because I would think it would go back a
couple hundred years
to the founding fathers and some people
that came over I don't know how [__]
old rugby is
anyway
um
so it's the Jesuit school high school in
Sacramento we not only hosted the top
teams from around the country to compete
with winning at least half the national
championship years since starting our
program in the 90s
if my sentence is confusing I mean that
since we started in the 90s we've won a
national championship every other year
all right well that's a hell of a run uh
but we've hosted teams from around the
world from countries like South Africa
England Australia and New Zealand I got
to get a video of the new zealanders
doing the Haka before the game I hope I
said that right don't want to piss those
people off man I've seen that before
that's amazing uh said New Zealand team
who was ranked number one in the world
was losing by two points As Time expired
but for some reason the ref said that
there was still time left in the game
they were alive allowed to drive down
the pitch
parentheses field even though the game
should have been older over and kicked
the rugby version of a field goal to win
the game
the kicker the stands were filled with
the New Zealand
teams family members they flew from New
Zealand to Sacramento wait a minute
you're saying some high school team beat
New Zealand a pro team
flew from New Zealand to Sacramento can
you give documentation of this game
Sacramento of all places some of my
buddies who played in that game which is
about three or four years ago have since
moved on to bigger and better things
such as amateur photography and high
school football coaching anyway Bill
tell them that we don't care about the
sport a couple more times
thanks for the laughs and go [__]
yourself
but we got to see if that's [__] true
that sounded true that was written so
eloquently
you know like the Bill of Rights
it's got to be true all right
Disney everybody oh I mentioned how I
went to Disneyland and I mentioned that
I recommended the turkey leg and I got a
lot of people saying I was 100 right
let's see what this person says Disney
bill I had the same reaction to Disney
as you I thought I would hate it as an
adult and I gotta say I [__] loved it
oh yeah absolutely man I didn't think I
was gonna hate it but I thought it was
gonna be way more taxing as a parent
and the lines were going to be bad and
all that and it wasn't and we went on
the weekend
and it was packed and it was still
awesome
um he said if your kid is not a manic
psycho and your wife is your wife isn't
overly obsessed with every detail it's a
great time well check to both of those
my kids cool and so is my wife
um he said I just sat back smelled the
smells listened to the Whimsical music
and ate fun food you have to be a
miserable prick to hate Disneyland uh
this is one of the truer emails I've
ever gotten it helps to be able to tune
out crowds so individuals don't annoy
you with their animal behaviors
you know even the animals didn't bug me
you know because I look at them that the
fact that if they were just animals and
we were in some regular space I would
have judged them more but for some
reason when they're at Disneyland
you think like you know what
that animal at least knows enough to
bring their kids to Disneyland so they
can't be all bad
um anyway and of course seeing your kid
be amazed is the best and there's
nothing as immersive as that for a kid I
feel like they leave believing more cool
[__] can happen in the world
uh then before they went yeah it is a it
is a truly for a kid it's a magical
place and for a parent it's it's I don't
think it's that wasn't that difficult
um once you get the turkey leg and all
that protein in you man
um I felt like that was my favorite ride
as a parent was lunch
this is great I don't have to stand in
line to get this well I did have to
stand in line but I got to sit down and
eat this is fantastic
um all right oh my wife can't drive for
[__]
dear Bill the human circus painted
I have no idea what that means what is a
circus peanut it's got to be some sort
of Orange
marshmallowy type candy thing
oh that's a circus peanut I think it's
called Circus oh so it's got the Cheeto
dust on it no no
do you know I've never had one of those
maybe because of the way I look it would
just be redundant and if I ate it it was
like you know they feed cows cows if I
actually ate a [__] circus peanut
um
if it's what I think you're saying like
there's a few things that just seems
gross do you know what like certain
things just seem wrong like you know
what always seemed wrong to me cotton
candy
it just looked like [__] these that
installation they put in the Attic like
why am I eating this and why is it good
oh yeah are those any good oh look at
those
what's inside of them
yeah same yeah those peanuts are just
like me you have no idea what's inside
me
other than some soulless Ginger
um all right I'm a 35 year old Jesus I
better finish this [__] podcast
before it gets dark I'm gonna I can't
want people to read like my voice just
cracked there dark
um
oh yeah it's beautiful
um we're coming back from the desert all
right dear Bill the human circus painted
all right I am I am
effectively insulted by that you son of
a [__] I'm a 35 year old dude from
Minnesota and I've been happily married
to my sweet lady love for the last 10
years that's fantastic congratulations
to both of you for all intents and
purposes
things have been great and I love her
with all my heart but she is absolutely
the worst driver I have ever had the
displeasure of riding shotgun with in my
entire life
well why don't you just say I'm driving
dude you can't tell me the second Tesla
figures out those self-driving cars
you're not going to figure out a way to
get one of those on the [__]
books
um anyway he says it's not aggressive
just to come to complete inability to
observe her surroundings and terrifying
she's a wonderful person but gets
extremely defensive about her driving
oh God is there anything worse than when
somebody sucks at something and they
won't admit it
at some point just [__] pass the Hat
onto somebody else that's the wrong
expression but not past the keys
um
okay though she is unequivocally the
mall okay she's extremely defensive
about her driving though she is
unequivocally the most dog [__] driver
of all time sir you write so eloquently
I'm almost worried that you might be a
nitpicker
it's an outside chance you know this is
really well written
for a guy who has podcast listeners that
need at least two seconds
to try to ponder what the hell they
they've written
um I love her a bunch but value my
safety as well as hers how do I bring up
that she's a violent Hazard on the road
without turning it into a blowout fight
every time thanks and go [__] yourself
every time she flips out about it
um
wait do you guys have kids does she
drive your kids
this is what you do
make the point again but before you make
the point just say to yourself I'm not
going to engage I'm not going to get
into an argument I'm not going to raise
my voice and let her flip out and let
her scream and yell and you just stick
to your guns and just say listen
there's there's stuff out there for
people when they drink too much you can
go out and you can get help
all right this is an intervention
all right you're a wonderful mother
you're a wonderful wife
you [__] you know you got you You're
great at this you're great at that but
you know
this is you know we're all not good at
something but you have to do this to
survive in modern society and I don't
want you to get hurt this is coming from
a place of love
from the bottom of my heart you [__]
suck at driving
if you suck this bad at giving a [__]
now don't say that
um
or just be playful
just be like honey
how many people are you gonna kill
before you finally turn the keys over to
me
she's like that drunk driver that
doesn't want to [__] hand it over
um
it is really difficult
it's it's I would think it's hard enough
as a woman if you're with a guy and he
won't admit
that
he's like you know he sucks at something
but women have the option of pouting
crying
using sex as reward or punishment they
got a lot of ways that they can work
their way around
you know you not agreeing with them but
as guys
but I don't know what what can
it's
they kind of use the same weaponry
when you're telling them some [__]
well here's one is there something
all right okay you know what you gotta
go mind game
all right we gotta fight fire with fire
so this is a woman so you can't use
logic
what you gotta do like you gotta go like
germ warfare like they do
all right so is there something that you
suck at
[Music]
that she is aware of and that she calls
you out on
and if there's any way like if there's
something
about your personality like maybe you
have a [__] temper
and what if
you went and got a therapist
not because you want to be a better
person this is all working towards her
getting help with her driving so if you
go out and what if if you go out and get
help
with the thing that drives her the most
nuts about you
oh dude we're going [__] covert
operations here
all right this is like when the makers
of Jeep [__] spread that rumor that
the Suzuki Samurai was tipping over and
killing college kids and everybody
believed that they started buying the
Jeep because the samurai was the cheaper
option
and evidently was just as fun to drive
this is what we're doing here with your
wife
we're going Chrysler Corporation we're
going with Lee Iacocca on this one
um
you just you work on the [__] that she
wants you to work on
all right and then maybe if you lead by
example
and if she doesn't then you can bring it
up and just say hey you know not for
nothing you said I had a temper and I'm
in therapy and I'm working on that
um
I'm not going to say that you need to
work on your driving I just hope someday
that this cannot be a fight and you can
listen to me and know that I love you
and I want what's best for you and that
you could kind of get past this
the way I got past my temper and I'm you
know
you know and she'll be like down you
throw that in my face and you'd be like
I'm not throwing anything in your face I
am like facts are not throwing things in
your face
or if she goes don't you throw that in
my face just say you know what
I don't think you're in a place
emotionally right now where this is a
good time to talk when you calm down oh
that'll piss her off but [__] her all
right no offense I know you love her but
[__] her just be like all right you know
maybe it's at some point
you know when you're calmer we can
discuss this like adults but until then
uh I will you know I'm gonna stay away
off the subject and this is the thing do
not leave the room after you say that
just sit down and uh pick up a magazine
okay there's no reason for you to walk
away You're 100 rightness okay good luck
sir
and God bless the United States of
America
all right
[Laughter]
um all right chick throws beer at me
all right woman throws a beer at you you
just gotta like that's just one of their
privileges they can do that they are
allowed to do that and you not only
cannot throw a beer back at them you
have to pay the [__] dry cleaning
bill just laugh and be glad you're not
married to her just be glad before I
even get through this just be glad that
you only know her as chick
be glad you don't know her name be glad
she's not
in your life unless you called her a
[__] you were an [__] or something
right hey Billy [__] tits there you go
go old school I was listening to a clip
from an old episode of yours where a fan
parentheses a guy of course was that
your show and had a beer thrown at him
by some drunk idiot woman yeah out here
in the desert yeah I played a casino it
reminded me of a similar story of
something that happened to me I was at a
bar with a couple of buddies and one of
my buddies is a really handsome lady
killer type he approaches a table of
about three to four cute but younger
early 20s looking girls he chats them up
for a few minutes and then I come in
like the bottom feeder that I am before
I even finished saying hi one of the
girls Cuts me off and says we don't want
to talk to you we only want to talk to
your friend
all right and I was like wow okay [__]
you then and walk away well wait a
minute how do you know you weren't
interrupting a threesome that was about
to happen
um you got a little in your ego there
anyway my my friend obviously sees this
and says to them wow that was incredibly
rude goodbye
I can't believe how much hitting on
women has changed see now if that was
back in the day my friend would have
laughed at me
and he would have [__] tried to bang
at least one of them
and then he would have told the story
about how they told me to [__] off and
everyone would have laughed at me and I
would have got a nickname out of it
look at this guys sticking together so
anyway
we laugh about how rude that was and
carry on back at our table a few minutes
later on their way out we happen to be
sitting close to the exit oh boy these
drunk idiot [__] are so upset and
embarrassed at their behavior that they
rationalize
I'm the bad guy of course and throw a
[__] beer at me on their way out of
the bar thankfully they mostly missed me
but my poor third friend got some
unjustified Collateral Damage I followed
them out for half a second screaming and
cursing at them that's what they wanted
uh then realized there wasn't much I
could do not like I'm gonna
not like I'm going to or allowed to
strike a woman over that don't think I
ever wanted to hit a woman so badly
after being treated so poorly for
basically no reason keep up the good
work old bill
what you should have said is hey lady
you you probably throw as good as you
[__]
[Laughter]
something like that
um
or just be thank you have a nice night
ladies just something like that the fact
that you act I gotta be honest with you
dude the fact that you got up and yelled
at him you you had they actually got a
victory out of that
[Music]
um
but just know this they probably were a
certain level of good looking
and they probably put a lot of
collateral on it on that which is why
they felt that they could talk to you
the way that they did they were also
drunk so I'll give them a little bit of
leeway here uh I can tell you women like
that do not age well
um because that's all they got is that
they're hot and when the looks go all
your left is with the [__] Within
which I believe
was a horror movie from the 70s or was
that the Beast with it I think the
working title was the [__] Within
when it was first pitched in England and
then they brought over the States you
know they always got to like water it
down for us the Beast Within
um
anyway
the Beast Within who the [__] would have
ever thought I'd bring up that goddamn
movie it was this weird-ass horror movie
when we first got cable
and there was some like invisible
[__] I don't know what it was but it
the thing literally raped some girl an
invisible devil
and and it was yeah it was making like
her titties move like it was grabbing
them so it was basically I don't know
what if they were shooting like air in
their titties
I mean on a special effects level for
the early 80s maybe it was but I mean
there was like all the horror movies had
like some form of sexual assault in them
when we were growing we were growing up
you know or you got punished for having
sex as a woman but that's that's an old
topic everybody knows that
um and by the way you know there's going
to be some creep that is now searching
for the Beast Within because they want
to see that scene
um anyway
so who knows God knows that money won't
go to that director whoever the [__]
worked on it 40 years ago anyways that
is the podcast everybody
um I hope you had a nice first month
of the year I had a wonderful month and
I'm very thankful for uh
uh you know this time off that I've had
and because you guys all come out to my
shows
over all these years so thank you guys
for that and uh that's it go [__]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday